>> Tucker: HOW HARD IS IT TO
THINK INDEPENDENTLY TO THINK
FOR YOURSELF IN SILICON
VALLEY.
NOBODY KNOWS THE ANSWER TO
THAT QUESTION BETTER THAN
JAMES DAY MORE THE GOOGLE
EMPLOYEE WHO WAS FIRED
EMPLOYER MEANT IT WHEN THEY
WERE COMMITTED TO DIVERSITY
THE OPEN EXCHANGE OF
DIFFERENT VIEWS.
THEY DON'T BELIEVE IN THAT
AND THEY FIRED HIM FOR IT
NOW HE IS SUING GOOGLE FOR
DISCRIMINATION U MANY OTHERS
LIKE HIM REMAINED IN HIDING
IN SILICON VALLEY.
JAMES JOINS US TONIGHT.
THANKS FOR COMING ON.
>> THANKS A LOT.
TUCK TONGUE THE DEEP IRONY
IS YOU THINK OF SAN
FRANCISCO, THE BAY AREA.
SILICON VALLEY AS
OPEN-MINDED.
>> RIGHT.
>> Tucker: DO YOU THINK IT'S
BECOME MORE OF A ONE-PARTY
STATE THAN IT WAS A COUPLE
YEARS AGO?
>> YEAH.
IT DEFINITELY SILICON VALLEY
STARTED AS SORT OF
LIBERTARIAN.
>> Tucker: YES.
>> OPEN TO MANY IDEAS.
WENT TO -- ALL THE TIME.
NOW IT'S REALLY THERE IS A
GROUP THINK.
AND YOU KNOW, WE SEE IT THAT
MANY PEOPLE ARE NOW LEAVING
SILICON VALLEY BECAUSE OF
THIS.
>> Tucker: SINCE YOU WERE
FORCED OUT OF GOOGLE NOT
BECAUSE YOU DIDN'T PERFORM
WELL IN YOUR JOB BUT BECAUSE
YOU TRIED TO TAKE THEM
SERIOUSLY WHEN THEY SAID
THEY BELIEVED IN DIFFERENT
VIEWS AND THEY DON'T.
HAVE YOU TALKED TO PEOPLE
WHO ARE STILL THERE ABOUT
IT.
>> YEAH.
I HAVE TALKED TO A FEW.
AND IT SEEMS LIKE IT'S
GOTTEN EVEN WORSE WHERE THEY
HAVE DOUBLED DOWN ON SOME OF
THIS DIVERSITY RHETORIC AND
PEOPLE ARE EVEN MORE AFRAID
NOW TO SPEAK UP.
>> Tucker: SO IF YOU HAVE
EVEN A MILDLY DIFFERENT
VIEW, YOU ARE CRUSHED?
>> RIGHT.
AND SO SURVEYS SHOW THAT
ABOUT 80% OF CONSERVATIVES
NOW DON'T WANT TO TALK ABOUT
ANYTHING AT WORK.
>> Tucker: SO, I DON'T THINK
ANYONE HAS EVER CHALLENGED
THE FACT THAT YOU ARE
QUALIFIED FOR THE JOB.
HIGHLY QUALIFIED.
A HARVARD DEGREE.
DO YOU HAVE A JOB NOW?
>>
?>
?UNFORTUNATELY NO.
I HAVE APPLIED TO MANY
PLACES.
I THINK A LOT OF THE LARGE
COMPANIES DON'T WANT THE
RISK AND SMALL COMPANIES
WANT TO BE BOUGHT BY GOOGLE.
THOUGH DENT WANT TO HIRE ME
EITHER.
>> Tucker: GOOGLE IS SO
POWERFUL THEY HAVE A ROLE OF
YOU NOT HAVING A JOB SIX
PEOPLE ARE DEFINITELY AFRAID
OF GOOGLE.
IT'S THE MOST POWERFUL
COMPANY IN THE WORLD.
>> Tucker: DO YOU THINK IT'S
A GOOD BUSINESS MODEL TO BE
ASSOCIATED WITH AN EXTREME
SET OF POLITICAL BELIEFS,
GOOGLE AS INTOLERANT AS THEY
ARE?
IS THAT A GOOD WAY TO
BROADEN YOUR MARKET SHARE?
>> DEFINITELY NOT.
I THINK THAT THEY ARE REALLY
SEEING THE PUSH BACK FROM
CONSERVATIVES AND FREE
THINKERS ALIKE.
>> Tucker: NORMAL PEOPLE.
GOOD LUCK, JAMES.
I REALLY WISH I HAD A
TECHNOLOGY COMPANY I PROMISE
I WOULD HIRE YOU TOMORROW.